So I'll be presenting on a very early phase two study that very early phase two study just open.
We don't have any patients on study yet, but looking at Glofidamab after CD19-directed CAR-T cell therapy for mantle cell lymphoma.
Here are my disclosures and objectives.
There are two approved CAR-T products for mantle cell.
We have Brexu cell, CD28 co-stimulatory domain, and Lysa cell, the 401BB co-stimulatory domain.
Each of these have been studied as therapies showing good overall response rates, but limited durability.
So in ZUMA2, we know that Brexu cell led to an overall response rate of 91%, complete response in 68%.
But as we're getting further out from therapy, we're seeing that many of these patients are relapsing.
And at three years, only 37% with an ongoing response.
This is the three-year follow-up of this data.
The all-comers represented by the purple line, those with a complete response represented by the blue line.
And even patients who had a complete response as we're getting out to four years or so, really less than half of these patients are still alive and without relapse.
Really no obvious predictors.
Here, regardless of TP53 status, K67, and others, there is some data that CAR-T peak levels do predict or give us some indication of patients that are going to have lasting responses.
So those who don't respond really have, as expected, very low levels of peak CAR-T.
MRD is, I think, perhaps less effective here as a definitive answer for really determining who's going to relapse.
And who's not, this is using Clonaseq, but perhaps more sensitive assays will be useful in the future.
And we do see that even out to 18 and 24 months, that many patients who have ongoing responses do have detectable CAR-T cells.
So 70% and 67% at 18 and 24 months, respectively.
Switching gears to Lysa cell, overall a similar story.
We're seeing most patients respond, 83% response rate.
With complete response at 72%.
Median duration of response is still under 16 months.
So again, most patients are losing that response.
Slightly lower rates of CRS and ICANS.
Here's the progression-free survival and duration of response data for Lysa cell.
And importantly, we now have data that patients that relapse after CAR-T do especially poorly.
So there were two retrospective studies presented at ASH this past year, and that led to two publications, both in blood advances, shortly afterward.
This is a multi-center study, retrospective study, looking at 133 patients who relapsed after CAR-T for mantle cell.
I think it was 87% of these patients that had Brexu cell, the remainder having Lysa cell.
And under six months overall survival from the time of relapsing after CAR-T, and that's regardless of treatment as a whole.
When we look at breaking this down further into time of relapse, I think not surprisingly, those who relapse sooner have very poor prognosis.
So those who relapse within three months, really it's about a three-month, somewhere between a two- and three-month overall survival.
Slightly better chances for those who have relapses at three to six months, and better for those who have later relapses.
When we look at which therapies are effective in this setting, I think as a whole,
it's generally disappointing when we're looking at single agents that are often effective in this patient population prior to CAR-T.
The one therapy as a monotherapy that does seem to be effective are the Bispecific.
So most of these have been Bofidamab that have been studied, small numbers, so 12 patients, but two-thirds responded with a complete response.
There are also some patients that receive combination therapies with some of the small molecules, so Selmides, BCL-2 inhibitors,
and BTK inhibitors that did have some evidence of response as well.
Similarly, there was a French registration study looking at patients after Brexacel specifically who relapsed with generally a very similar story here.
They also saw that the T-cell engaging therapies, again, mostly represented by, I think in this case, all Glufidamab, I believe,
did seem to be the best opportunity for a response.
With very low response rates in other therapies.
We designed this study initially about four years ago with using Glufidamab in combination with another therapy as a consolidation after CAR-T to prevent relapse,
a concept I still favor.
But for reasons that are outside of my control, these things change.
And ultimately, it was repurposed as a salvage therapy given lack of data in that setting.
And so part of our goal here really is...
is to establish the efficacy to determine the impact on CAR-T cells
and to see if we might use this alone or in combination as a consolidation strategy in the future.
This is the study design.
We'll be using Obinutuzumab, the higher dose, as previously discussed, of two grams per meter squared on cycle one, day one,
followed by Glufidamab step-up dosing, as has been described.
We'll also be looking at CAR-T cell levels.
As well as immunophenotypes, the CD4 to CD8 ratio, potential markers of exhaustion, LAG3, TIM3, PD-L1,
and seeing if we might have some impact on CAR-T exhaustion as well as cytotoxic markers.
Future directions in this setting, I think, again, the maintenance or consolidation approach is preferred to a salvage therapy,
ideally with some of these combinations.
There is some data.
There was a TARMAC study that came out of Australia looking at...
ibrutinib prior to cell collection and throughout CAR-T cell.
I think they were using Tissa cell in that study for mantle cell lymphoma with some promising results.
There are also dual-targeted CAR-T cells.
There was a publication, I believe, in December of this year coming out of Wisconsin using a CD20, CD19-directed CAR-T product.
Early follow-up, but overall looks to be promising.
Hopefully, some options for improving outcomes in these patients.
With that, I thank you all for your time and happy to take questions.